the great Johnny Bench the Hall of Famer
joining us on the program Willie McCovey
passing away at the age of 80 class of
1986 Hall of Fame and one of the more
feared batters left-handed batters in
the history of the game and Johnny
wanted to pay tribute to Willie McCovey
good morning Johnny morning Dan thank
you he was the most feared i I i sat
back there and I'm trying to think of a
pitch I can get him out and I don't have
one I don't have a pitcher I don't have
a left-hander I don't have a
right-hander I don't have any pitch that
could do it and he couldn't have been
the most gentle gentleman I mean he was
just a gentle giant one of the things I
remember most in of all of it was when
he was went to the Padres and Dave
Winfield he was there and on third base
so Dave thought that you know with
Willie at the plate why don't I steal
home he chose pitcher throws it I tagged
Willie I take tag Dave out and Willie to
this day now if you can envision he's
standing there and he's looking down
right at Dave and Dave still lying there
and he puts his bat on his shoulder and
he reaches up he takes us takes off his
helmet with two fingers lays it down on
the ground takes his bat laser beside
the helmet looked at Dave again and just
turned in with the first base
why would you said he never saw I always
asked Dave about this is where I tell
that story every time I see Dave anyway
the Hall of Fame and everything else but
here's my Covey and he was you know he
was the shift was the original ship but
explained that ship so Johnny because
this was we see the shift now and it's
in it's in every game but they were
doing this to Maccabi back in the 60s
weren't they yeah yeah I mean we you
know it didn't matter I mean that you
know you talk about some of the guy that
you couldn't get a pitch out what you
couldn't get us you couldn't you
couldn't sneak what is there somebody
said past him you couldn't think
daylight past yeah you could hit any
pitch he could go he could go out and
get it he could turn on anybody's
fastball and and you know one day
Perez was playing behind
can and Willy we did happen to get one
in on Willie and he popped it up
I caught it behind third base right on
the line down the third-base line
I caught the ball that's how high I hit
it I mean when he hit it it went to the
moon and but he was the original shift
and it didn't matter and you know to
play on those knees what'd he have 400
93 homeruns I'm just I'm bets out of the
old kid having their bubblegum cards and
everything else any of that yeah 469 I
don't think he had 500 home runs so yeah
something like that
but his maze and he hobbled and you know
it was but could you imagine if he
didn't so much he didn't play in
Candlestick if he had played in the
ballpark that was like if he played in
Yankee Stadium oh oh no I mean you know
Ruth would have been second Aaron would
have been second I mean it was just it
was just amazing what he did I mean
selling you know the people who sold
Candlestick to San Francisco to build it
I mean they took him out at 10 o'clock
in the morning said look at this piece
of property wouldn't bear take him out
in the afternoon or an evening when the
fall came rolling in and the wind hit
balls when I wife tried to throw
somebody out at second some days I would
started it short just a little over
towards the leg what was a tougher out
than McCovey though and you're in your
own nobody nobody really nobody no Mays
was McCovey was easier to get out than
Mays yeah cuz you get Mays to chase a
curveball or slider down in a way and
you know Willie one day he's doing that
rocking back and forth with his bat you
know how you spread out and he'd go
swinging back and forth and I'm sitting
back there squatting and and you know
he's done this about six or seven times
you know he's here to go out toward the
pitcher and then his sweep back and he
stepped out of the box and he said you
gonna call a pitch or what yes soon as
you quit looking back here oh man you
got me well I mentioned he had 469 home
runs as a giant he had 521 home runs to
anyone yeah so he matched Ted Williams
with 521
you know but I just amazed Danny you
know he just every time to be around him
and you know and if you could see the
digression the relation of his body and
he'd come back to the world of the Hall
of Fame and you know there was the
wheelchair then he'd be on this crutches
but you know I'd go out to give IRAs at
Candlestick he was always there you know
I could go in and see he and Willie and
you know and the Giants - I mean their
credit I mean they treated their players
just unbelievably and they kept Willie
around and of course he was so revered
and such a great you know for them for
the game of baseball he was just a great
humanitarian great everything about it
but it's a sad day and you know
unfortunately you know we start to lose
them you know as we go well it's nice
that you thought of him and wanted to
pay tribute because at the age of 80 you
know how many are gonna be you know
willing to do that and have we're around
to see him play so I appreciate you you
know remembering a lot of it you know hi
buddy Thank You Johnny that said Johnny
Bench for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]